you know it's the end of the year when
magazines give out awards to get
publicity for their dying industry the
whole point Free Press which sells more
copies it's true you do get the press
but I doubt it sells copies first GQ
made Colin Kaepernick Citizen of the
year for obviously taking the knee he
got the press but he drove NFL viewers
away
GQ seems poised to copy him then there's
glamour glamour naming Linda Sarsour as
one of their women of the Year star sort
champions Sharia law and once brutally
mocked women brave enough to challenge
it including a victim of female genital
mutilation how is that Pro women who's
doing glamorous research Hamas so why
would editors make such choices well
they're not just expressing admiration
they're desperate to publicly express
their own moral correctness elevating
their position among their liberal peers
it's please see how aware I am of social
justice issues such actions bring good
feelings from the identity politics set
but it's a political sugar rush the
feeling fades fast and then you're left
alone and broke case in point
look at Teen Vogue don't look at it
after deciding to embrace progressive
politics they had to close its print
edition costing 80 jobs offer a
desperate stab at social relevance
I tell GQ to learn from that mistake but
judging from their past political
stances I doubt they'd listen they put
the ass and ask God so anyway what are
your thoughts Dana well I was I was
gonna ask you like there's this kind of
thing work for them because you I mean
you know the publishing industry better
they're almost like if you do this it's
a way to maybe try to get some cachet
with advertisers to see how relevant
they are but you're alienating half your
audience right then and there there's a
lot there's a lot of guys and you know
who would who GQ haridas football were
ticked off there are women half them
well I don't know who reads Glamour
anymore I stopped reading it I get it
for the makeup toe mustaches I guess
that's surprising it's like when the
time does their Person of the Year yeah
yeah yeah he's something that's a little
bit edgy
remember when they did edgy to them ed
Snowden yes person of the year and but I
thought it was interesting that he
declines to do interviews and he didn't
do an interview for the species
basically you got a book that in it
right Jesse yes I'm gonna invoke the
view rule which is I would like to be in
GQ one day so I'm not going to take that
as a compliment you will never be GQ
maybe if I do I'm gonna hold that hope
but I will say in general that what they
do is the left will lionize these
America haters and like a Cindy Sheehan
or the guy that was on the cover of
Rolling Stone the Boston bomber Keith
Olbermann or someone like that and
there'll be the flavor of their month
and the media will milk them and they'll
profit from them and then they'll just
discard them and then you know they'll
be in the left-wing media Hall of Fame
but these awards don't mean anything
anymore as they used to because you said
in the monologue the industry is dying
but what kind of citizen was Kaepernick
this year he didn't work he was
unemployed and the only thing he did was
sue the NFL JJ Watt he I think raised 37
million dollars for hurricane victims
that's a lot of money I don't know how
much Kaepernick donated away actually
I've found something Kaepernick donated
$25,000 to a group that celebrates cop
killers so if you put that on balance I
really just don't see who the real
Citizen of the Year is JJ well yeah well
I mean like this is to me is I I can't
even believe they made this choice but
then again like you said when you look
the rolling stone with tsarnaev etc so
it just seems very sensational and just
really I'm trying to be self-promotional
shock value and then you know he's like
he's he didn't a good interview for it
but he provided connections to friends
and people that could talk for him you
want to provide me quotes okay he posed
for the picture etc okay great
he still doesn't have a job yeah okay
yeah right you know why I don't I can
understand Kaepernick to a degree
because raising the issue which is
everybody loves but Sarsour I mean this
glamour is supposed to be you know a
feminist magazine they claim to be for
women and they're elevating a woman who
thinks Sharia law is the way to go crazy
to me that's crazy but I must say the
reason that is
not the reason that they're putting her
out there is not what you're citing it's
because she was an organizer of that
large march back and right January and
she found but you know woman's like no
but I think this is in other words they
are focusing on the fact that she has
become a major organized she's an
american-born
Palestinian a palces a fascist and she
is somebody who has been now as a pretty
young age rising up as a star in terms
of the women's movement ashes star well
that's that's we're talking about women
as a major political you know she'd this
kind of woman female leader fine women
do not need somebody if you ever heard
what she said about these about these
Muslims thank you sick I would agree
because it involves the mutilation stuff
which right just beyond exactly my
tolerance but I must say that I think we
have a different point of view on
Kaepernick because when GQ honored
Catholic they said and some of his
friends say this is a guy that would be
making millions and therefore he's given
up money he would be prominent he have a
job
right right and he's given that up right
so he has been self-sacrificing from the
magazine from his friends point of view
and I think people put him in line with
people like Muhammad Ali who gave up
three years in his prime to protest
destructive be self-destructive and he
wants to be a starter we'll put up
numbers like a starter and then maybe
somebody had you know pay you and play
well that's true in the forty niners no
it's not fear because in fact better
than people who are being hired right
now to play football all right I got a
guy by the way I just got drafted an
entitlement program not everybody gets
to be a starting QB